caos y desesperación en medio de la
multitud en haití cientos de personas
asaltaron este camión con ayuda
humanitaria que se encontraba a las
afueras de una estación de policía en
los cayos una de las ciudades más
afectadas por el terremoto
la gente de los cayos está pasando
hambre todas las casas colapsaron la
ciudad está muy mal estamos sufriendo no
encontramos que comer cuando llegó el
camión con la comida la policía puso el
camión dentro y no quería distribuir
eventos similares ocurrieron en el
pequeño pueblo de vídeo en donde se pudo
ver un grupo de hombres tomando sacos de
comida de un contenedor la frustración
ha ido en aumento en el país con unos
daños sobre las carreteras que
ralentizan la distribución de la ayuda
el primer ministro ariel hungry afirmó
que su país se ha visto abrumado pero
sus planes siguen en pie para intentar
llenar el vacío del fallecido presidente
job en el móvil
me he comprometido a dar lo mejor de mí
para poner a mi país de nuevo en el
camino de una democracia que funcione
con la organización de unas elecciones
buenas libres y transparentes tan pronto
como sea posible liv
naciones unidas envió una delegación
para hacer un balance de los daños a
pesar del alto flujo de pacientes en los
hospitales ellos han aplaudido la
respuesta de las autoridades haitianas